armed fighters in the democratic
republic of congo's north kibu province
take part in a ceremony
following their surrender to government
forces around 70 weapons mostly rifles
were also handed in
our work in the rebellion was to steal
and destroy the peace among the people
this is why we the leaders of the bush
troops decided to leave the bush
to bring our children out of the bush to
embrace a better life
the provinces of north kivu and itauri
in the east of drc were placed under
military rule last month
to stop escalating violence between
armed groups
president felix chisakedi put the army
and police in charge of administrative
court and policing affairs and two
generals were appointed as governors
replacing those who were elected
the cleanup operation is already
effective with several villages
recovered
we will continue to hunt down these
armed groups wherever they go
[Applause]
violence has plagued these eastern
provinces for years
with more than 100 armed groups
operating in the dense
forests and attacks on civilians has
surged recently
killing thousands of congolese and
displacing more than five million
so many support the president's actions
i feel very happy really happy to see
our cousins our brothers and uncles who
were once fighters
surrender since the military governor
has been in office
we see that the activism of the armed
groups is on the decline
now they are starting to surrender
without gunfire
president xi zakiri says his decision to
impose the so-called state of siege
was prompted by the suffering of those
living in north kivu and itauri
critics warned the security forces could
easily abuse their mandate
but supporters say military rule is
already making a difference
victoria gatenby al jazeera